yo yo yo click sure y'all can hear it
here to talk y'all all right chat here
now oh I see I see the desktop audio so
that's good I just don't want to start
it again into day see what's going on
Chad I mean you gotta talk to me talk to
me jack
yeah there we go it's uh just reset yeah
okay I just want to make sure that day
game okay yes I can hear works now all
right I will go down my man that's what
I've said let me restart my thing so I
could see the live updated check sorry
y'all
apologies apologies as I'm figuring this
thing out yes yes lo the budget I know
we do it we do it a lot I need to get we
need to get you over to extreme I'm
gonna get an e like a traumatic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we definitely back now
hopefully please let me know yeah I hear
them can you dig it
we are live the remix welcome to the
island podcast and the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 149 and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got already in the will
of the wisps Call of Duty warzone game
stack live and Harrah's easy road or the
PC to discuss so we gonna get right into
it I want to introduce the Lord whom the
IOP is not only proud to call a true
friend to the room there was positivity
as a content creator but philanthropy
extremes and former career as NYPD is
the epitome of the expression true blue
introducing the created host of
breakfast with boom Xbox Factor
primetime gaming and the double barrel
gaming YouTube channel my podcast
brother from another mother and fellow
graduate of mr. Lee's game training
program live from New Rock City and
making his return into the realm of the
Lords mommy Lord boomstick Excel how you
doing sir well listen it's great to be
back man this is uh this is a very
trying time in the world and I gotta
tell you the more podcasts that come out
the easier it you know it eases people's
anxieties in the world and of course
this is one of the one of my personal
favorites and one that I think everyone
Tunes into because of the you know the
positivity that comes from the entire
realm but also you know you guys don't
pick sides
you play games and I thought they that
is what is important facts brother facts
by the best well Sandman first off um
definitely one two it's been a while
since middle so it's good to have you
back that's yes number two you know I
really want to thank you personally you
know obviously you know we had a special
thing that just went down on
double-barrel gaming for our brother
Lord dizzy you know I'm saying so I want
a salute shoe salute on Mike Ibarra will
me hood Rand outdoors any games everyone
that came together because boom like you
did a fantastic job I knew you were the
right man host you know said you could
galvanize the people for something
positive and it gave me a lot of faith
in our community for so thank you boom
for hosting and doing something special
man people don't know how much
behind-the-scenes you do and you're
given I just want to thank you content
create a host to contact create host
salute well I I definitely appreciate it
but you know real quick I had talked
that we've had talked privately before
going live it's kind of just wanted to
give the community and a breakdown idea
of how the monies came through what was
taken by Google and what is going to
dizzy and his family we collected
exactly fourteen hundred and forty eight
dollars Oh
Salah my wife you know my wife Joe set
and I we added an additional fifty two
dollars to make it fifteen hundred oh
and after Google took their thirty
percent cut the monies were left at nine
fifty Wow
and this is where Joe set and I we had
promised prior to going prior to going
live on the show that we would pick up
the entire thirty percent plus make sure
that dizzy and his family were got we're
getting maximum dollar that's was so we
are adding six five hundred and on
whatever it is dollars more plus we are
paying the transfer fee for a PayPal
because they do charge you to send the
money and so he is getting on the twenty
first a total of fifteen hundred dollars
millions billions over that yard
we do it for days where for good
billions millions of dollars brothers
and you know it's funny because no you
know obviously being retired and not
working it's just one check coming in
per month but and I'm not rich but we'll
wind up happening is because of the
cancellation of III which of course King
and the rest of us were very devastated
he was kind enough to kind of push the
envelope on getting us our money sooner
I basically I took all of the ìiî monies
that were already spent and just moved
it over to I dizzy and his family for
the total amount of $1500 and you know
what I gotta tell you you know what
what's impressive
what's what really makes my heart beat
an extra beat is to know that I'm not
even at four thousand subs I'm a very
small channel and to not only have these
star power was like we had with the road
out before and a will knee hurt yes and
zemi gain yes come through we had my cue
borrowed this is a small Channel
Mikey borrower is big-time this is the
guy thing that not only was a you know
you know held a very very high position
within Microsoft he also is now the vice
president and general manager of
Blizzard Entertainment and that's no
slouch position absolute have him come
through and spend over an hour and 20
minutes with us to do something special
like this for dizzy and his family is
pretty incredible but more so than just
that yeah the community yes my god you
guys and gals responded in such kind
full-fat when you break it down we may
technically 750 dollars per hour
oh that don't bad for that one in a two
hour stream do you understand that there
are some streams that don't even get
close to 500 yeah I don't want that much
money so a big tip of the hat if you
will through this entire community that
came together they put down their biases
with with
I'm so wore [ __ ] Wheatley went out there
and did something for good and I gotta
tell you in with the way the world is
now this really ignited my faith in
humanity absolutely old folk baby we're
gonna definitely bend me to the
community right now because everything
that came through so so get that bended
knee bending up for everyone who came
through who show positivity even if you
didn't donate that was a man so salute
to you we've been in need of y'all we
got some super chats at it can you take
care of these super chats like notice
crest up Smitty Schmitt oh I may be a
little biased but my brother boom in the
iron Lords podcasts are the best after
salute to my fellow New York I dizzy we
got you fam we walk the walk together no
doubt a $2 shot from Bret let me simply
let me summary gay yes sir yes sir the
crest goes up for every K as well so
salute man special day real quickly boom
anything have you got a chance to play
anything recently no but these last
couple days everything going on yes as a
matter of fact I got about maybe two and
a half hours in Tori and the will of the
wisps the reason why it's not 10 hours
or 15 hours is because quite frankly I
cannot stop playing the division is oh
my god it's so good it is so old-school
Division one bank NYC no streets yes and
you know what I say that that loop is
kind of dope I'm here a good big vet I
got a touch I can't stop upgrading my
stuff and I just beat um I'm halfway
through I just beat the main guy and I'm
just going after now the yeah I be I be
be kib McKean and I'm heading over to
beat on now that's Saturn it's Neptune
it's a few other planets that I gotta
take down and then I'll get back over to
Washington DC and help those folks out
you know I'm saying though don't talk
about you
you scrub through dusty place maybe too
big oh come on slow down like this not
like this oh well you go slows ready bad
another game Kagura bandulus castle guys
oh stop it
anyway if you knew we got the footwell
doctor for us but we actually won
Horseman down unfortunately your please
y'all send your thoughts and prayers to
solve and lady solved you know he's
going through a situation right now he
needs all the love and the support he
can get you know you guys don't know
behind-the-scene how much my brother
really you don't really take mix the
extra effort to be here you know I'm
saying here at home but everything
that's going on in the world you know we
just wanted him to be safe and also
lately soft to be safe and much
successful on a procedure and things
that they're doing
so again if you haven't um please send
solve a message man he needs your love
there for real so we are going to
continue on stay with three [ __ ] in
the gaming but it's all good
my co-host with the Como's who I now
appreciate doing Obst but brother from
another mother the difficult game Kagura
Lord of reviews and the house of the
young both MAME Lord addict I doing sir
pretty good
I like how you smile oh you feeling good
about that best of you feeling good
[Laughter]
preciate it
bend the knee to your street black
knowledge it's not as easy as people
think could do that's all that's all
what else what else you can play me for
table check I knew we loved boo -
awesome job
I knew we loved bold for a reason keep
killing it thank you very there's a
pleasure and an honor to know you and
call you my property already no lower
for it take that's what's up
so you just saw so you actually be ory
man got it all very difficult game you
don't let these games live hey don't be
looking on from our review
tomorrow I'll be launching tomorrow on
my channel I got a review coffee like a
day before I would have had it sooner
it's just already decided to come out
when I had work so you know you still
got it that's what sets us up and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this a.k.a the XS gamer ooh the Lord of
combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement Oh beloved Lord King how
you doing sir I'm a little depressed man
what's going on a little depressed
what's going on I really wanted to come
through on Thursday and my butt was
sitting there made sure that the PC was
on and everything was ready sat down on
the couch I was playing some destiny I
said you know what I got at least a half
an hour let me get like 15 minutes well
because I work at night yeah and I woke
up and it was like 9:30 10 o'clock so I
said you know God works in a way that I
guess maybe he didn't want me to put
that on air for the brother and you know
it's I'm shipping it out to him you know
personally so I guess that's between me
and my brother you know because you know
dizzy is there every time we go live and
he's there for us and you know and I'm
like you know I really wanted to be
there we know your situation is
everybody everything everything is
really wild right now so let's go what
honey
emojis yes there's just this week well a
shout-out to the bleeding edge of who
did that for you
what will happen it was it was Orion
will already downloaded now i'm shout
out to me for being the absolute fraud
that i am you know
this super fraud i'm wearing a badge
well i never finished the first one so
the boy has to go back and finish the
first one before you finish the second
one or plate a second when i'm not gonna
be a fraud and just play the second and
then like I'm about that life
um downloaded Yakuza um I started a
little bit of that but you know I'm
playing Kingdom Hearts so I was like
y'all gotta finish all the children are
mortal now see this is what takes up my
absolute time anytime a game is giving
me any type of headache or any type of
crap you know what I'm doing I'm playing
that so I got one of my characters
absolutely maxed out at me at level
right and I got the next one at level 19
and she's about to be maxed out so both
women are maxed out basic normal knocks
out and I got the guys that you know I'm
bringing up the rear
but night every time you reach the new
pinnacle and you thought okay the story
part is gonna be over yeah hell no this
roguelite got more story so I'm pretty
shorted summing-up didn't get to play it
but it's a pot in there where you gotta
make a supreme sacrifice this is how you
become a rabid fan of something family
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody got a vending me oh well boom
into the realm everybody put your
shields up put your crossovers in the
rail thank you brother for this we have
to support one another if we don't no
doubt another crest up for our Lord
Smitty Smith mm no I can't baby onto
something with - okay so you know
definitely playing destiny and the DLC
I'm sorry slo-mo oh I downloaded the
joint for the division I booted it up
but destiny came out with the boot on
that Tuesday production and I'm gonna
tell you right now once they put new the
Chow is coming coming they peaked your
dart and he put out trousers a fight
where they both I love it it's always
good when they when they do this because
they both in their back and they both
compete at the same time we win right
don't we win as gamers when they you
know I'm saying because I'm a huge
destiny fan I have not been back to
destiny oh my god it's shameful I played
through I know I beat you and I wait a
couple of months afterwards I I just
dropped it off though you know big you
know boob is it like they like into
booze eat those right this Lobo be a
panty nation it they shut down and go
for UK they sent down the visual
production with that one new exotic they
provide with zero usefulness Wow one
exotic and in a different mode and then
you got back to the bush
I would give it to the day you know Lord
[Laughter]
spread that ruinous into rum to IOP not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear
so um I'm gonna shout out my boys own
sister Wilhelm scream for that trials of
Osiris when we go to the lighthouse
we made some things happen man we got a
little gear little stuff going on man
Charles is back you not going to the
lighthouse because all the sweat ease
our routine right now all from school
those arrested me and my eternal you
know competitive yeah turn it off
because what's happening they said oh
all the sweaty is a quarantine finish to
the camera this bring this is the
official patch five saluting plan ready
I was doing that yo so trials of real
science returns with my favorite game
modes of all time shot to eat Bacchus we
talked about it on the last word this
Friday little prep you know what I'm
saying so he's doing that chop the
screenshot the sinister Foley that we
had some fun with that giant shot the
hard light being in the most annoying
meta right now if you not use a
hard-line oh you wouldn't know I came
down to the pressure oh then what I used
it I realized why everywhere
shut the hot light coming in hot cuz
right now my lights coming in hot and
that better right now it's crazy right
now if you're not using a hot light you
ain't with it so that's what it is oh
wow man you ain't with the two lot of
super chat love how y'all rep xbox Final
Fantasy 7 remake it's an abomination
right it's not what it seems like kid
you know since I was a fraud on the
first Ori you know I said I I felt bad
for for jumping did you notice a but I
did jump in for a little bit like Bulls
fine I was a fraud on the first oriental
about three decks oh okay you want to
get technical IB or in the blind fours
and IB or in the world of the West in
like a week oh okay that's which a good
daddy we got floating back gonna have to
shut your mic sir a slow-mo man destiny
as DLC better than the division two
trials of Osiris by itself is better
than the whole destiny oh oh oh oh bad
is crazy today you already know so yeah
but doing that but I did touch a little
bit we'll get into that Dory topic you
know I'm saying and then I'll call of
duty war zone for King I got a lot to
say when we get the kids topic about
that and oh just real quick y'all just
something different outside don't you
know just with everything going on you
know I just want to talk about it real
quick like you know obviously you know
we know pandemic all that good stuff but
um I got a bit like when everything's
you know shutting down and stuff like
that I've never been as more fortunate
and happy to be a gamer right cuz if you
think about it you know I'm saying with
sports and just physical activity and
going outside and the way things is
right now you know I'm saying like yo I
am so appreciative that we have these
things to do so in a sense like you know
less Xbox Live and PSN do something
crazy
we're okay and I'm saying it's far as
just do it stop positive to get our
minds off of what's going on so salute
to all the gamers out there you know it
really real
means a lot to still be able to do what
we love and we definitely appreciate it
start somewhere to get into that dude
because you know wondering one of the
biggest things with with the situation
going on is that yes it's serious yes
it's scary I don't think people should
panic I think people should just try and
do they'll be precautious but the social
distancing that they want us to do yeah
you know you don't really think about
this and you know no one has actually
talked about it but we gamers are
already prepared for that thankfully we
are in a position where even though you
and I may be on separate ends of the
coasts or separate ends of the country
you're on the west coast I'm on the east
coast and we somehow managed to figure
out the time and get together we are
still hanging and we're still talking
what still hanging in fun so if you are
you know if you know cuz look there's
gonna be a lot of anxieties that are
gonna be happening this isn't going to
be over quick this is not a
unfortunately it's not a quick fix they
are working on it I have some inside
information that they are doing some
really good things and I want people to
understand that it is it's you know it
is not going to be the division out the
boomstick is ready that's the able to
understand that play some games watch a
couple of podcasts try and stay away
from the negative ones you know I gotta
tell you man even with the craziness is
going on stay away from those negative
podcasts because I don't know really
there's a lot of people out there
pushing this unbelievable narrative and
where you have to really you got to poop
on one console or the other you can't no
have love for of them don't don't fall
for that man don't don't put yourself in
don't fall for the banana
exactly that's right go Eddie Murphy
talking right there don't move
my brother scream who just joined now
you missed you shout out scream I shot a
job for trials oh wow here we go I gotta
throw the crest up it I might throw a
fraud alert up after these two well shot
at the slow boat backs laugh of being
petty with the $10.00 suture warlords of
New York greater than trials of Osiris
and all trash destinies seasons combined
I should even be reading this forte is a
week Mike having fraud because he don't
play the better Luther shooter that is
Division two PS frostbite is a one
dollar story
yo he go for everybody in their super
chest
they gotta be honest with you I think
I'm gonna have to you know team up with
saw the greatest avatar the world has
ever seen
so the fact that you spend your money in
order to catch this fade he goes yeah
brother
oh don't worry
the folks at Bungie support your opinion
all right the roadie are throwing up the
fraud alerts sorry slow we gotta give it
to you go boycott it throwing it up free
to your Bochy to the room I see a bad I
hate it had to be you but the Lords have
been playing boom has already received
the royal treatment before please check
ILP 73 you haven't been on stood 73 solo
you've been on at the
then we did the Microsoft big one we
didn't resolve for that so I think I
might have been wasn't it 100 that I was
on also yes you're right yes no you're
right well why'd you watch it as well
you were probably yeah kiss Oh
Christopher kiss smooth fine on a super
chat be safe everyone playing everyone
impacted by the bull stuff going on
anyway or a lot of not--that's Xbox
series X get delayed oh man I want to go
into that really because yeah I honestly
believed both of them get delayed on
primetime game tomorrow night and I I
got a different opinion on that I think
this right because let me tell you
something and I'm telling you from
firsthand knowledge most of my statues
come from China oh oh one of the peels
came up and I was supposed to you know
give my guy the money and it comes from
China and I've noticed that in the
community we've been talking a couple of
guys hit me was like yo you know they're
holding packages and one really big dude
in the statue community has at least
seven packages being held by customs and
they're not letting these through so the
fact that these consoles are made in
China right predominantly that's where
the factories are and you know China is
back up and running and doing anything
[Music]
the the level of fear paranoia
surrounding things coming from that
Orient is high so if it's justified or
not I believe that the level of delay
might happen and does it change the
narrative or what's not what should
happen you know Microsoft stomping the
boots off for PlayStation 5 but I really
think is a high possibility smooth good
man we're definitely touched on that
wind get to series x2 that all this
stuff brought up yeah like I said well
my gosh you weren't here from 100 but
you were 73 is when you gave your top
five right yeah so what I usually do for
people who return you know I'm saying
what I had without for you at the time
what's resonate with to all right has it
even three
city and night yeah final fantasy seven
ironically don't jab knees looked out
and did you gaining black so I just want
to know Lord boom it's anything changes
the fear holy five retained well I mean
look let me just say this Resident Evil
298 unfortunately has been put down
torsion number two Oh
Resident Evil nineteen has taken its
place in regards to favorite supreme is
just so important I know you fell in
love with a game before that broke out
[Laughter]
oh yes so basically that you remains
because I know that a lot of people are
upset about the whole one-year exclusive
with the final seven i'ma say this man
if you don't have a PlayStation 4 now
you're probably not gonna buy one but I
would definitely highly encourage
because things have gotten so cheap with
these consoles that you've really kind
of just cheatin yourself you let's say
you have to go out and buy every first
party game but and they got three good
ones
one of which courses Final Fantasy seven
that demo was dope Nam I'm not gonna
front I didn't realize that there were
three ways to play Wii III picked the
one way it's kind of like a Final
Fantasy 15 which I did I enjoyed the
demo but I don't like that control I
like old-school sitting back and you
found out about that that classic yeah
I'm gonna do the classic one but I'm
really looking forward to that game so
nothing has really changed but I am I
want to just kind of add a caveat yes
because I don't think you've ever asked
me what my favorite console yes I've
never asked you to
and my favorite console and I want to
pull it out of storage because I have 86
games still port is the Sega Dreamcast
oh one of my favorite consoles of all
time with the Xbox 360 nipping at its
heels but the Dreamcast was of course
during the grandfather era and when I
tried and a lot of times going back and
forth Queens and their world I'm not
imported everything funny story about
the Dreamcast when he came out they had
a four game one extra controller package
from Japan that was $1200 Wow
for the import mm-hmm so I you know as a
very young police officer you know my
father would always was like you know
you gotta invest your money sup oh I did
my deferred compensation since rookie
but then I got bonds on top of that I
kept getting bonds there you know two
bonds every month
I wouldn't even open I would just kind
of put them in my my sock drawer cash
these things in I don't you know I
cashed in about 30 of those mofos yeah
so yeah Dreamcast be number one but yeah
the the core 5 hasn't changed and you
know what I mean its greatest gaming is
and it could be I can easily add five
more so when you when you talk about
someone who's been gaming since 1978
those are the ones that kind of stand
out
you just gave me a new epiphany I have
to throw that in with the top five that
could create a lot of it's just eating
conversation some added pigs blow a boom
debuting it today episode you know I'm
saying so that that's what's up but I
like that I'm gonna use that van moving
forward all bad his JD gave up put the
crest up with the Lord's Sega Saturn
baby
oh I have the white one from Japan in
storage
oh yeah that's a seven-shot Eric Josh I
got given what I gotta give him - who
did that face their dream cats who did
beautiful baby was super aggressive
[Music]
ready now so we got the poll results
from last week and um let's get into
debt and wait is the question I don't
know what the question is but we'll
figure it out anywhere so I believe it
was the the PlayStation 4 as far as
their exclusive lineup was it a goat of
all time you know I'm said that was
amazingly the question so the winner of
a very close to me way I LP pole with
dominating 48% of the vote you know I'm
saying was nah pump the brake fam no
guarantees any of those well beggars
here's a governor that second place was
yes greatness of that lineup is
unparalleled and last place with only 30
percent I don't care
Yatta keep that same energy with the
PlayStation 2 group participate in the
pool
Lord bold man but I never got your
feedback on that um what did you feel
did you feel whether you don't last of
us
um ghost of Tsushima MIB to show final
fantasy 7 we make you know is that as
far as an end of a generation lineup is
that the great one of the greatest end
of generation lineups of all time to you
or do you agree with the people now I
mean listen you you can't argue the the
stout fulness of what they have for them
right I mean we have to understand that
you know you have neo - mm-hmm I don't
fancy
seven you have ghosts of Tsushima and
you have less of us - you got Emma MLB
the shoulder last year of its
exclusivity opposite to close out a
generation and it's that tough to beat
tough act to follow and beat mom because
you know you are closing it out I am
gonna say this though
I just hope yes that the PlayStation 4
community actually goes out and supports
these games by buying em and not just
putting them in lists III think that one
of the the biggest misconceptions with
with all the console generation you know
extremists if you will is that instead
of playing the games man they are really
just you know being so happy to stack a
list and writing on that's kind of
ridiculous
you know what I'm saying I mean listen
okay yes MLB is good be negative it's
gonna be everywhere Final Fantasy 7 is
gonna be on Xbox next year but if you
really enjoy Sony's games and there's
110 million consoles out there I don't
know if you can be as a fan as a fan of
the brand I'm not saying that if even if
even if those games so 15 million that
that's not good that's fantastic
but at the end of the day when you vers
it fifteen million sold on one
particular IP versus 110 million and
that's a real low percentage and again
it just makes you wonder
all of these most loud they don't you
know when you it said when people are
very quick to just go on Twitter and be
social media or social media boobs
instead of a gamer and that's really
what it comes down so I live with that
no duh yo Lord adequately get those
super check sir we gotta build a crest
up some super chance
[Music]
we gotta get to JD gaben okay so we got
a $2 from JD gamer
good morning Lord Sega Saturn baby
hazard your dragons a go-bag best action
RPG ever pull then we got super champ
from a dragon what oh I thought you said
oh no no no I said what a we dudes are
here fraud you ain't in your forties I
ain't reading you a virgin the game we
had a Vette siddhis people just because
they get into these topics
number one is you are free to speak now
or some new generation stuff let's go to
what's happening but what I want to
really ask cuz the quality of this game
is absolutely amazing it's it's a good
game in general I've looked first off I
don't know about boomin king did you
guys play it yet yeah I turned it on I'm
not gonna throw it and sometime you say
you know what that's not how I play
games I don't play at the end before I
even got a chance to play the first one
so I can't honestly get today
masterpiece
without finishing their first
masterpiece so I'm gonna finish the
first one that I'm a boot up the second
one but the fact that you know it's Xbox
are exclusive it's in-game pass a
beautiful thing it's free it's an Xbox
gamepad and being crappy I love the fact
that you know they're in there and they
also give you a warning when other games
are leaving so this game would never
leave and
impasses forever and check that chess
out on that game pass man
the boy will be back in that game pass
so I think I am the only one that beat I
don't know how far you guys go in terms
of like what kind of platforming you're
playing so you know I just want overall
impressions boom what did you think of
some of the platform that you came
across well I'll say this I I'll say
that I mean this there's a lot to really
love about this game thankfully I have
not came across any bugs or any anything
that would well I mean I'm only 2 only 2
hours and change into it I'm really
enjoying it I think that the music is
captivating it is haunting I think
visually is one of those games that
almost at every turn you want to stop
and take pity on social media so people
could see how beautiful it is I gotta
tell you as for an opening of a game
oh and start with the with you know with
the you know with the AL being a baby
and they kind of work through the
seasons and they kind of work through it
ends being what seemed it's almost
teenager yeah is just incredible I mean
it's and you know what's even more I
think what's what isn't spoken enough
about is how they do this without saying
one more simply do this with the visual
presentation and the more and the music
that is just so good and and you gotta
remember this opening isn't some
5-minute little thing it lets a little
bit the log is real for real so it's
again it's again I I'm only two hours
into it I can't really speak on I I'm
able to carry I got to double jump I'm
able to carry three different you know
the abilities in there I have I think I
found 604 so I have my core three that I
like but
I gotta be honest with you like I like
the sticking to the walls I like the
double I think it moves great again I
haven't had any problems maybe later on
I I may think differently but this is if
you're not I'll say this 2d platformers
Metroidvania is in particular or not for
everyone and I get it yes but I have to
tell you if you don't at least try it
and you have game Pass bring up a bushes
I got you the bush for you brother
bushes right there something that needs
to be experienced yes maybe it's not
perfect maybe it launched with some bugs
but this is a true experience and what's
even more impressive is that King is
always saying who did this for you could
play game services brother do it doesn't
peculiar from purchasing the game once
you've tried it in game pass see what
this does is let a lot of people
understand that it's not a barrier sir
the gate is wide open
Wow use the absolute amount of freedom
to choose with your dollar you're voting
with your cash now see so now that you
have this buffet in front of you you can
taste things did you see what I was
doing with my app on my phone for gaming
past I was going down the list of the
games that I played and I have installed
that I will sample and when I decide
that they're worthy of my dollar
not these one-and-done games that I'm
locked into an I'm finished on I am the
purchase said game to show support so
that's how the New Age is playing
brother get out of the stone Age's and
step up to this digital age first off we
got a super chair from Smitty
cuz I'm pretty sure you the one that
called me know that was 108 ok you're
good I got the collector's edition of
war here we go right here for you city
package you get for $50 is almost like
stealing simply fantastic well then we
got a $5 2% from JMO money order - it's
affected me like no other game the
emotion of power this game portray all
the way to the end is nothing like I've
ever felt it what's funny is uh what um
what Boone was talking about it gets
worse like you can hear when uh you got
a scald needle or cognate I was in a
discord and I was play it I'm like man
that can't happen like they doing that
now you told me now let me jump in man
because um again kind of the same thing
I know I was listen to you play a lot
you know try not spoil but yo one thing
that they have captured it boom said it
perfectly you know say is that with with
minimal text with minimal voice they are
able to convey such emotion and the
highs and the lows like you start to
feel away you get connected then you
combine that shout the Lord Garrett
Coker man the incredible music that this
game yes so you coupled that up and I
want a shout out my boy said Terry has a
great article up on the hoods of gaming
net right now um talking about that
interview they had you know I'm saying
then shout to my boy rage virus if you
haven't checked it Lords he gave him
down there he has when you got a review
up I've already - I mean if you like
boom said again if you are on the fence
about platform because even in his
article he said I don't like platforming
games coming into the review he said
yeah and foot and for me I'm not that I
don't like them it's just that you know
as an older gamer I've kind of worn my
they've worn a welcome a little bit to
me so it's always harder to kind of wow
me when it's a new one right so for this
game and then the first you know say at
least the first two hours and I'm like
yo I can't stop playing like this thing
is so addictive I'll even go above and
beyond that and say this is one if not
the best platformer I've ever played it
but you know what's doable you know I
played all the Mario games and I think
what makes us different is Mario gets
hard but it's never really there you
know what I'm saying like it's always
like that middle ground difficulty right
this game there's some things that I was
just like how they even come up with the
costly yeah they just sit around the
little chalkboard you just say how we
gonna mess with the players today we
also have to remember caucus and this
team is 50 people yes and split up in
different issues yeah they're not all
working in the same location I mean
listen again I understand that there
were some initial bucks with with the
reviews which is why I kind of you know
it took a little bit of a hit mmm-hmm
but at the end of the day once these
things get rectify mmm-hmm this is and
and I think will stand the time as being
considered a masterpiece let me get our
what away real quick though crest up
what over eight with the fight on a
super check I could see Ori to getting
that Xbox series X 120fps update can you
imagine that Y of word its it'll be
crazy man
you know because again the graphical
fidelity the engine is moving it looks
great I can't wait obviously for that to
see that what's going on but the other
thing that surprised me I wouldn't speak
to addicts point is it's more
action-packed than I thought like what
your first ball I like what I was
fighting the last boss that I was is a
party man like I had to mute them cuz it
was getting so crazy yo the threat of
danger and the action and things you can
do you know I have a good question for
you guys I'm curious you don't say as
far as that but it reference to moon
studios but we'll talk about that later
but the whole thing is like man they got
one man they really you know I'm saying
got one shot to braaap I see what you're
saying he's saying it's one of their
best um you know exclusivity generation
I think I would agree with that I think
both of their games is probably besides
carpet because I do think up that's a
better game right
I think cut pay and the reason is
because it's a boss rush game and that's
what I like as well mmm-hmm
but I think all of their Studios let's
see that's that's what always trying to
like preach is you don't have to have a
stream triple-a title to be a great game
you don't have to have a couple hundred
million dollars back in a game to be a
good game obviously this game suffered a
lot
technical issues right I had a restyle
reset the game once like the whole game
from like the middle of the game I just
play almost the entire game over yeah
it's it's pretty bad especially you know
I don't have an ex like the other lords
here
nah it's it's unplayable in the ass
don't even try oh oh oh you kick I don't
know buddy don't do this because it's
not in color but uh JP something is
coming for you he kick is a fraud
services what are the choices for people
we vote all these games we will rent
them going towards a digital age and you
don't really own those either let me let
me break it down for them because
obviously I don't read anything you do
alright so maybe you're new right okay
and this is for you for being new saying
that this is for you
alright um but what I'm going to explain
to you I'm going to explain something
very easy you don't have to have game -
that's right Troy and no and no point in
time do you need to have that alright so
this it's an option that can give you
more options now what you can do with
your $50 every month or every week you
rich
obviously you're rich a position of
having so much cash that being able to
play everything you would rather be able
to go buy everything okay so you walked
inside Game Stop and I want you to do
this because I'm gonna do something that
you can't do and you're rich cuz you're
rich and I want you to purchase every
game aside game pass I want you to go
purchase all of them
alright I'm gonna do the same thing that
you're gonna do I'm gonna go download
every game right and I'm going to do
that for 1495 dollars a month and you're
going to go do it for like forty five
hundred right so I want to know who
actually is winning you the guy that has
so much cash that he can just go put a
mortgage every time he goes to game stop
or this fool right here
right here there's wearing their dad
near to a change you know I put this on
specifically for you because I knew you
was showing up I'm cheap this shows that
I'm cheating the bracelet to watch all
this stuff I'm cheap come take my $14.99
and I'm gonna stay inside game pass and
if I happen to like a game that they
have to beat me into loving I'm going to
buy it I'm going to go and go to
discount all right so I'm sorry if game
Pass is not for you I understand that
you have rolling out here with that
dough I'm not doing that sir my pockets
on lien and Microsoft understand what I
mean right now and I need game pads to
get me through these lean times brother
so I'm sorry but you're rich though what
you can do though next time put it in
color since you're millions oh yeah a
million visits up right they offer the
bars bilious millions millions you got
go from je mo money whoa I've never felt
more for Ville and either addict he's
talking about them or is one of those
games I don't think you've took off the
but uh or just one of those games where
they make you really like sympathize
with the villain Eric J moon still uses
on another level with platforms I think
as far as maybe the older Mario's like I
didn't really like Odyssey but I do
think the you know this game is probably
the best platformer on the market right
that's a little odd fish out to my
brothers on the next podcast man we
talked about it yesterday
yeah like the the the discussion was
brought up you know is it the one you
know the best platformer is Jen and um
you know the moderate Barry Odyssey guys
came out a lot of people it's I think
it's like I said I think the reason that
it makes it better is just how difficult
it is it's like a lot of platformers
aren't really that hard
mm-hmm so you know you spend the
majority of your time just breezing
through the levels this is not a level
we'll type a game like your Mario's this
is a metro vania type of style that
hasn't left forming unit which a lot of
them do but the platforming is actually
difficult so traveling through the map
is just as hard as doing the you know
fighting a ball even what I like I do
it's on the radio I mean that probably a
big thing but I like that you couldn't
go left and right in this like you know
some schools you're just going one
direction for them right you're going to
the right now yeah like that you know
say it just gives a little different
depth to it also little subtle things
like you know when you're on a higher
point and you just hold down you can
kind of get a peak of what I was gonna
say and I want to ask you this kid
because we ample cuz we come from the
era of the mascot yes a and like you
know you remember I'll see the tendo out
the gate marry order the boombastic this
you know the revolution that is then an
aggressive Sega you know I'm saying with
Sonic blast process and this is what we
do right you know we have bomb even bomb
you know that we notice you know say so
my question to you and I also breathe
attic know what I clued him it's like
should Xbox get behind or we as like
their mascot cuz we don't hate on Master
Chief we know what he represents we know
Marcus beings we know but like I feel
like and I had this conscious romatic
like oh I feel like they need a new no
no them okay so you don't you say no let
me let me explain why I felt like I feel
like in order to have a new mascot you
have one that's more iconic than hail
and they're never gonna give one oh yeah
okay so the way my Microsoft is actually
pigeon-holed a sofa and they hit a
homerun
yeah you know so they turned into Barry
Bonds like you know how when Barry Bonds
was all-around player and then he got he
hit that home run and people were locked
in today he had to perform on that level
so I believe the halo has pigeon-holed
them Rhino you are synonymous with this
character I feel that but let me let me
flip you one coach I yeah you guys are
right halo you're gonna say that
PlayStation has the same thing with
Kratos and they also have other ip's but
I don't think instant
I don't think PlayStation had like
PlayStation has amazing games right
don't think that anything is iconic as
Master Chief okay you can go and you can
show anyone like any person that doesn't
play games Master Chief in nine times
out of ten they're gonna know what that
is so that's that thing from hitting
from xbox for a room you show them
Kratos some might know some might not
know bro you show them Nathan Drake no
one's knowing that don't be
disrespectful don't be disrespectful to
Dee Dee drink of all my know I
understand you know I don't think Ari
also is the lack of voice true when they
put the voice to sonic on the cartoon
shows like wow I always thought he would
sound something like that yeah when when
they give the characters voice they
bring him to life and I think we're past
a part of the Disney era mmm Nintendo
will always be locked into that is they
have so many characters that are
synonymous with their system I don't
think or we may I might be wrong if they
do or III or II don't have a bow oh we
got we got a to Bill's to Bob brother oh
you're very the Lord will be hood with
the $50 super check and we're way behind
just wanna get him did we get it we
catch up I'm will be hood and I would
get to borrow wolf I wish but we gonna
talk about that or that next time which
you will be stay tuned for the next one
trust me when I tell you Atika we catch
up what is it what yes please yeah okay
I didn't see it and I'm trying to get to
it so that's a shot from Brack spit bars
King Oh his wife Oh shake it the whip
from Smitty Smitty leave King alone
coming at his head please sit down you
are the same guy
[Music]
Wow they don't like where they go for
the kiddies rail riders Victor do you
think boo studio could reboot blinks
it's a soul special I think they could
do great with Sonic which could make
Sega proud of them to be honest with you
I don't think I do think they're gonna
work on a new IP it's probably gonna be
multiply it because Microsoft has an own
new studio but if Microsoft forever buy
them I actually think this is the
perfect studio to make a banjo kazooie
like I knew and I think real needs to
step up and do that I really think yeah
but I think they really need to utilize
rare and and work their own IP because
I'm sorry I think the studio is great in
doing what they're doing
um and I and I want them to flush this
story album I don't know if it's gonna
be a three like you said you already
finished it so maybe you know a lot more
than I do
but their 2d type of storytelling I
think that lends to something else maybe
they can do a game like Castlevania you
know something like that I don't know
but I wouldn't want to see them do a
bunch because I want rare to put forth
that effort to make that game you know
yeah I like you know the Pirates game
but no I honestly truly feel like banjo
kazooie where it's it's so old and was
never like people know what magic
kazooie is but a lot of people don't
know Microsoft even owns it right yeah
so if they would bring that back in a
great way like rebrand to do whatever
you could that could be something new
that people can look at local that's
that Microsoft game yeah cuz banjos I
caught it right yeah you know not to get
too far off topic because I know we got
to get back to what we're talking about
but and I think that if rare can't do it
because supposedly they're working on
three IPs alright the continuing would
see if these ever while we know we
already know and it's supposedly a third
project I don't think it's banjo kazooie
they Microsoft should seriously consider
getting play tonic Oh clearly
just which is packed with all x-ray our
people the entire team is all x-ray or
licensed them out to do one game you
know I'm saying because you know they're
gonna do it right because banjo kazooie
is their heart and let them take as much
time as they need to either redo one
what should be fine or actually just
make a new one in the seer I I
personally disagree because magic was
good but I want a new direction for
banjo kazooie like no like they're gonna
you know go towards that's why I'm in
studio to make it because they're
creative with platforming I feel like if
you give them the tools to make another
one dose it they're like okay this is a
banjo kazooie did this is what we did on
Ori let's find a good middle ground
right yeah that makes sense
so you want a reimagining like the way
that uh a lot of these new games like
Final Fantasy
let's take final drastic I still wanted
to stick to its roots
yeah but Final Fantasy still stuck to it
root I mean I guess the the formula of
the facade of the visuals and they
flushed it out into this day and age
this is what I've seen I didn't play the
game so I'm talking from a fraud
standpoint like if I were to compare it
to the kind of change I would like to
see I would like then banjo-kazooie get
like a Ratchet and Clank for the ps4 boy
you know what that's a very underrated
game I'm a Ratchet and Clank
no I'm like morphine for that when it
drops that and I'm so upset that they
didn't do a jak index I really wanted to
Jack index to this generation and I'm
really really pissed off to be honest
with you but the Ratchet and Clank if
they would do something like that that
was a pick saw game bro yeah it looks
like though you want to talk about
really really good PlayStation games
yeah you start right there because that
was so early on in the generation yeah
it was phenomenal
the reason that I really want new studio
to make that more than anyone else yeah
because they showed an Ori that they
make platformers based off your
abilities and not the level
and I like you know look at all the
abilities banjo had that you didn't
really utilize to a hundred percent in
those games
no I feel I mean listen this is some
great points I wanted to say real quick
to you know it's a whole mascot thing
and then almost far as moon studio
acquisition you know I think that I just
want I just wanna think that's happening
probably probably not but I just what I
want Microsoft to promote just a little
bit more maybe that's just me as far as
far because they don't own them maybe I
don't know I don't know what's the whole
thing I just don't feel you know I think
it's one of those guys that when you
play gasps it speaks for itself and then
word of mouth is gonna get out and it's
gonna do what it do but it's one of
those things that you know I wish they
kind of get behind then which was
leading me to my question which is
probably gonna be a preview Pro is that
like because now this is Moon Studios
just to bangers now all right yeah all
he wanted we already - you know I'm
saying like is it to that point well
filled I'm just gonna have to have to
back the truck up do you you think they
stated me to stay with like like with
this okay I'm gonna fold i'ma say this I
think Phil did everything that he
possibly could do to put this in a great
light okay because it's been on that
summer jams clean every time we get a
chance to its in-game past so it's a you
know it allows people to play it first
they was also doing the pre download and
it was on the dashboard for a while so
if you didn't pre-download it I'm pretty
sure it stayed on your dashboard for a
long period of time and then when the
game did actually come out I think it
was in a bigger box on your dashboard
it's like they promoted on you yet I
think they gave it of the proper light
so maybe I'm kind of wrong but I think I
think it's gonna have to sink a swim now
and see what it does
I think or II was already like the
number one so thing for like two weeks
on Steam it's already sold well right I
think that it's a moon studio thing I
think moon you know once the
independence they're like look we would
like to be purchased by someone but we
just brought out Ori the water let's see
how that does for ante up oh yeah we
know we have it how we might not necess
certainly have IP but people know we
good and to your point when they put or
e1 on switch it is still in like the top
5 and 10 on the eShop or e11 switch so
they might do on the back end and say
you know what let's keep this multiply
money you don't say and stay where we at
is what is the second party whatever it
is like they may want to just keep it
with Winnie yeah from their standpoint
if they're doing well what you do I
think Microsoft was able to buy them
they would have involved mmm good party
there are certain companies that say we
don't want to be bought but they low-key
do they just want the right price for
instance you know playground games rec
they said we don't want to be bought but
they're right prices we don't want we we
don't want to make racing games for the
rest of my life are you implying that
they really forced into doing quarries
for the rest that was that was finish my
statement so Microsoft came in the back
door like okay you guys don't want to
keep making forces all day long how
about we give you three to two extra
Studios you can make an RPG and you can
make something else and your staff can
rotate between them so they don't get
they don't get burn out I think that's
the reason they bought it I think that
they went to Microsoft with an ideal
that was that was similar to fable and
they're like we will let you do this we
gotta be Bob like we can't let you use
ip's like that we've already been burnt
by letting people use our IPs and then
they the moment that gays built their
like we out pieces you know I'm gonna
tell you this Microsoft right now is out
of all of the companies they have really
been very aggressive they're stacked yes
there were four there were four
companies that I think that are almost a
no-brainer that they should own and they
should worked it filled himself if he
hasn't done it already has worked should
work really hard to get this done a Sobo
is an automatic body yes
we've seen it we've seen what they did
with the plague exhale we know what the
flight sim is coming out it's
unbelievable
Moon Studios come on folks I mean this
this should be an automatic now again we
don't necessarily know if maybe they're
you know one of these Studios you know
we got to be independent I just want to
bring up real quick but the guys that
made spider-man
I don't know they kind of was waving
this we're gonna be independent and then
I guess that extra three zero you know
be purchased mm-hmm was just because a
spider-man that spider-man was such a
good hit that that would that that would
guarantee their future paycheck because
I think one of the biggest fears is
going into a scenario to where they
don't know what funding they would get
if they got purchased by someone and
they don't know what type of games they
would be making well you know what
considering that Microsoft is very
forward-thinking and already very clear
with their ideologies they've already
they've already said that people are
making what they want to make so I don't
get the concern they wanted Sony because
they've had that's complete speculation
dude you can use I'm not speculating I'm
saying this is who I would like them to
buy you're saying that they don't want
to be bought as if you sat the boardroom
I'm saying who I think they should buy
you're saying no they want to be bought
by Sony because they're 110 main which
is proven facts cuz they've been working
with them for a couple decades for them
to buy would make an impact in their
first party in their Xbox game Studios
is play tonic because they could task
them to do banjo and it would not pull
anything away from which no rare does
not usually like going back to older IPs
they've said that publicly so if they
can't get rare to do it and I'm one of
the people banging the drums for a new
banjo kazooie that's classic not in the
direction okay um that would be the team
to do it because it's all x-ray or
people who have a love and respect for
the IP and the last one is mdh are more
one that is could have been purchased
them that's again that's one of those
companies that fits the Microsoft
ideology they're small they put out an
incredible game the DLC is coming we
know they're working on two right now
and this is a team that could seriously
add on to their you know their their
portfolio and remember the one thing
they're big about Microsoft is having
you know different types of games in
game pass not everything is a shooter
and I think is a racer now if there's a
third person you know bro dude shooter
right or is the next fight on the smash
brothers let's go I don't think that we
got to see more from them before just
but just go ahead okay let's get these
super chests at it we got after that
after digi we got uh we got our area we
got air ninety four moon is a bunch of
people around the globe not just a
normal studio got a five dollar super
sharp frank gaming forte slow-mo acting
like division two version of a pony
don't get mad you backed the wrong horse
everyone can't win in this game so stop
backing a loser
yes be for life right there listen maybe
it's interested to see you know like I
said stay tuned for the poll in that one
you know how that gets handled as far as
them you know as far as the independence
and stuff but again we can't say but
this game is really really phenomenal
and um if you haven't got a chance to
play like I said its own game pass check
it out even if you don't like action or
platformers give it a shot and see what
you think because it did for a person
who's been platform 14 over the years I
was very impressed so uh
salute to those guys Moon Studios again
if you haven't checked out the review
for my brother nor plays virus please
check it out on ones gaming got net he
had scored this game and reviewed this
game he gives it a very detailed
impression and from also from a non
platforming perspective which I like and
he gave he gives a lot of kudos oh yeah
check that out when you get a chance but
that's all I got to the next topic
Oh Lord King you are up man with some
there's a war going on outside oh man
it's a friend oh we got to chat to super
chat all banned shout to my brother
you already know my brother kids small
final switch at Xbox game studio biggest
purchase is ZeniMax if they get they've
done they good okay true that's true
that'd be a big get the JD real quick ok
somebody getting JD who get the JD JD
gamer ok Lords do what boom did what
what are the other lords wishes from the
future Microsoft acquisitions my top 5
our Abzu studio nd a charm insidious
crime give you mine real quick Crytek
Crytek Christ yeah how would that rise
the money and just let's get them to
making games get crisis despite him I
like low-key
be like that chronic I was just actually
gonna say that uh cog that you know what
the purchase itself with with of course
being able to bring back rice on the
room which won't end this potential
right but we also got to think of the
crisis with that but more more
importantly than those two things it's
that Crytek engine that would be big for
Microsoft because the dividends that
they would be able to make by licensing
that out listen folks if you think that
that Crytek engine is old
I implore you go back pop on Ryse son of
Rome which is a launch title from 2013
and I'm telling you your eyeballs will
fall out of your head it's only I think
it's only worth being this the IP be
involved like cron takes pretty much
dead like we can't buy a dead student
what they enjoy schooled us they said
that Amazon nice oh no no that takes
well kiss moves rise they do P you know
would be crazy if Microsoft bought rise
years ago and they didn't tell anyone
and in the launch title for the next you
know even more crazy and Sony bought the
rights to it and they're so I'm on my
xbox right and I see it says free war
zone he said Call of Duty wars okay so
I'm I'm allergic to call of duty call of
duty with the duty inside the bushes no
I clicked on it I don't know why I don't
know blessed be the boy clicked on it
free daddy daddy daddy well
it was I don't know why I clicked on it
I was bored or something something
happened YouTube was doing something
that I wasn't like you would have
clicked on it but really like a guy yeah
I hear oh I know why I clicked on it
talk to me I was looking at YouTube and
it said it's for tonight done and they
had they had a crown on top of call of
duty and he said Wars on it had two
tiers a fortnight and then I saw it on
the on the thing and it was like free oh
yeah was LL Cool J yes my god yo I was
amped by the time I already hit download
I said this was the greatest trailer yes
one game that I've ever seen be honest
which I mean the last time was probably
on Gears of War emotional for my
backpack of my guns that was tell you
okay
so download the joint right okay I
couldn't wait long I was playing
something in destiny and it was like
your game is ready I was like boom by a
hundred gigs though the tutorial my
problem always a Call of Duty was the
guns fell crap
because I played that little thing that
they had last year and I hate it how the
guns from they felt like paper mache
guns and was weak mm-hmm that's a
destiny still boxing your teeth in these
guns
I think they stole some people from
Bungie so okay so you put you in the
Jays like a match oh boy
call it I believe they're on a PD called
duty in general I'll be the one but um
they've hit six have come to support and
they have smashed on apex legend who did
2.5 in the same period and all fort like
grew slower but then they quit I got to
10-minute to a week so we gotta see how
goes through the week but the millions
have already spoken it's let's talk
about it Babbitt of anybody get a chance
to play it listed or boom let's get you
in have you got a chance to play it at
all yes yes you know what here's the
thing I gotta be honest because I'm an
old-school selfish kind of player I
don't really like the whole battle
royale thing even if it steeps ok um I
downloaded it I have to say graphically
it's impressive for free to play I
played only two matches and the first
time I fell way way super far away from
my team and I tried I got killed trying
to climb fence but I did play a second
match
and I'm like you know what after 20
minutes I'm gonna give it another go
mm-hmm but it's it's just really the
whole battle royale thing is just not my
bag I feel you I would rather play the
game and shoot stuff in like the
division that single player but if I
want to team up with my brother or you
know what slo-mo mental it's great
running around collecting weapons and
chain not your name sorry I'm maybe I'm
just too old no no listen
I wouldn't get to be I got a lot to say
about that but um what's gonna say is
let me just ask you this before I passed
out it um in comparison to the battle
was you've played right how does it
stack or is it is it better is in the
middle it's not better like where do you
rank even though I know that's not your
honor because I even used to call but
your battle royal bubble-wrap like I
literally said it's the bubble wrap I've
went on record have disrespected battle
runner I am sick of battle right so my
question to you with all the mumble
rappers it is it little this is a little
baby is a little dirt is who was little
one is it like for you to shake it a
bumble right there now I've been
watching I'm gonna take this a lot of
people opposed adding somebody in the
bushes okay Mike
yeah somebody's a lot of people have
been posting like some crazy killstreaks
yeah right so I'm watching on Twitter
and they put up their two-minute video
I'm like man that looks dope I'm gonna
say this
I don't like fortnight the whole
building thing in the bushes for eating
don't care what
second off I just needed to make sure
that everything was right oh my gosh
cold hamburger two hours from now okay
what the bushes back Oh attic bushes
return continue getting back to the
topic at hand is this for tonight if you
if I was ranking the for yes shop or
what you're being played
for tonight gets put in there before
okay um followed by that would be pub G
I don't like pub G I played it I bought
it I supported it
I played only X man if you look at my
smile a time two hours at most it's just
I don't like it apex legends when I like
what they've done I put a lot more time
in seeing X and I did any of them be
cause of my bias for titanfall my
favorite time I have spent over a
thousand hours playing both Titan will
flame Titan for one and two so selfishly
I have to say based on the videos based
on watching other people play which I
normally don't like to do oh because
they have the skills I just I just don't
have them nor the patience to want to
play any games I have to say that right
from jump man Call of Duty gets number
one place they really have responded to
the whole phenomenon of the free to play
and it's Call of Duty now again I don't
have the time that other people have and
this is just a an opinion based on what
I've seen what I've watched other people
play in other videos but I am gonna say
mama said to go mama knock him out
so do the trailer is was dope i watch
that trailer three times by the way mmm
so I'm gonna say that out of the for Ike
I rank it as number one I think that
it's gonna hit 10
if it hasn't already it probably
attorney after three days no that's big
bubble football means you don't like the
genre that's a lot better
Nord addict did you get a chance to play
at all we just eat chips already Oh cuz
it was like a honey the only game I
really like is is apex so you like to
sharra I just don't know the characters
and no but he like it's not just that
like you know you when you come up on
squad you like what are they okay it's a
pathfinder okay they can't do this they
can't do that like aspects like that
mm-hmm
you know at the end of the day like
nothing's gonna dethrone fortnight we've
seen this you know four night dad
Ford I dropped some big call to I mean
they literally they literally made a
fortnight chapter to let me actually
just a dick what about the cold Call of
Duty name right they gonna drop this
when the next one comes out you know
what red I'm a glad you
I'm glad you talked about it talk about
it one more at top I'm gonna do this
right because this deed a little woozy
vert right now was on his low high and
I'm gonna say um that fortnight is
little boat oh my god
yeah many in the street he was all over
the place he got fat right now Bert was
in the gym together right he dropped it
right I remember
they put out some free to play crap
lashing the guns was garbage and he got
things face smashed in by fortnight for
tonight with a who is these whack dude
but I think the Call of Duty brand they
their fan bases different different
that can stand up to that judgment among
everything
I'm a little biased I'm gonna tell you
why I'm very biased because
fortnight's smash my blueprint feels
like we do it better than you
you know they push through the bushes
they stood they took the money in the
most unlikable do I want the most
unlikable douches because the for
tonight crowd is completely
diametrically opposed to the crap is
ex-military Dubrow who grabbed you up
dudes for tonight is these candy-colored
bookbag to be bullied and pushed into
the corner I want for tonight over we
gotta get the kress ball brother Oh what
are we dragging TV with the file our
subject happy birthday to be oh happy
birthday brother
Oh our souls for gifts come to card and
get this smoke I'm four mile but my
reflexes in my 20s natural-born killer
that's what's up you know say happy
birthday brother Ben salute 108 I've my
hat - you might be on to something man
we're gonna get to it but kick it I hate
you which is that people forget what
three or four months ago this is a big I
had a black hole and was trending on
Twitter for three days right now because
the black let me ask you there's no a
day you make a good point
for tonight
4:19 drop something people like Call of
Duty one hahaha but let me W add what's
gonna happen is the pudgy people that
been want something new is going over to
Call of Duty the fortnight people are
gonna go call of duty and then the
fortnight people go back to for that let
me ask you this and I want you to be
look at it very intently
I hear you point all-valley anything
that has come against fortnight has been
forced to bend that knee
they've been big you came out at all and
then you get crushed and you've been
bending the knee I can't but this is
different
this is not division this is a machine
this is what this is arguably the most
success the man in right the most
successful franchise in gaming this is
what both platforms tend to by and free
to play and just what MPD my only thing
is you don't think they got a shot you
think it's just case closed
[Music]
there's this thing called you know a
whole studio developed to make fortnight
you know sooner or later the next Call
of Duty is going to come out they could
be competing with each other
mm-hmm and then you're gonna have the
stand point where is active Activision
are going to look at it from a
perspective like okay how much are we
really making from this ran like my
girls in dated MicroSociety they got the
batter case yep I don't think Activision
is a company that's set to make a battle
royale game that is why fortnight's
where it's that that's why epic is
worried that because they know how to
make this game okay giant [ __ ] and when
they have been concluded the mat will
stuff into a black hole
failure where fortnight drops I'm not
gonna front the worldstar this know that
let me get let me get boom in boom whoa
job
a black hole was trending for three days
no doubt nothing wasn't even happening
they had people literally just
live-streaming to the black hole Call of
Duty's hot right now but sooner or later
but when that's gonna react oh they're
not like Sony they're not keeping quiet
oh you know what I want to just add to
the the conversation is that if this was
pre call of duty modern warfare I say no
they don't have a chance because you
gotta remember that black ops you know
thingamajig with no no single-player
that they put out they charge sixty
ducats for people enjoyed it for a hot
minute and then it fell off because it
you know it really wasn't that good well
but you have to remember this is this is
an Activision this is a Call of Duty
post modern warfare read that everyone
loves a single campaign even people that
normally didn't play the single-player
campaign played it the multiplayer which
I don't play was fantastic from what I
understand and now they've got to the
free-to-play sold you gotta remember the
good grace gay gamers are a fickle Bunch
they when they want to remember but they
forget very quickly and now that
Activision is in the good graces of the
game unity with mana warfare England
strong single-player a strong
multiplayer and they have this
free-to-play thing and I think that they
listen I put it this way no one's gonna
ever say that one game is going to take
down fortnight it's gonna take a lot to
do that but I Got News for you I think
they've just punched him in the mouth oh
and right now for Niners like that
Hurley Rock six million block
six Billy let me get sweet million to 6
million he's called a duty dude I'm
telling you I think these are the
brothers to get that stand up to Stas
their own get the balls off this is our
cake let I go for it when I go for the
keyboard this up I sign up say it's like
they're not fortnight out in two rounds
and it's a whole fight kind of oh yes a
fight at the end of the day I can't take
away what coral Duty is done right it's
changed the game it's the franchise that
finally made me stop playing halo
regularly I'm a king of muck because
well you know halo was in his bag two
three all at for whatever and then I
never forget where Modern Warfare drop
that was a phenomenon right that's what
pulled us off you know I'm saying and
made us do that whole competitive thing
now rock with them all the way up to
about black ops 2 I want to say and then
I have to wipe my eye job is rinse
repeat
yes I see what y'all doing it's fun it's
just I'm done with it so my new drug
became that something that's literally
my whole competitive thing in a nutshell
now I can't front you know what you know
how I feel about battle royal and when
pop G dropped right I just needed to
know what is this battle royal right why
are people going crazy
right so I jumped in and I'm like I
realistic simulation tension of the last
person the circle I get it and I was
riding for pub Jeep and I'm saying then
the wort start to expose the engine you
know what I'm saying I started then the
leak though that not frequency with the
updates and then you know what Knight
came in and stole emboss and made it
better is it
and I gotta give it up as much as I hate
it what happened you know they made it a
phenomenon right for that became what it
is so now we are to where we also I
download this thing I got a debuted new
emoji you are king you may be on to
something bro let me tell you man um
that engine
oh my looks good not thing is amazing
60fps I plan on an X it looks phenomenal
it is great the cinematics look crazy
it's just gorgeous the tutorial was
fired a gun handling was crazy then I
seen perks with with killstreaks and 150
players the fire they got the eight they
stole the apex ping system where they
like you over there over there instead
but the joint that I like where they
really onto something that they doing
that I see nobody do is one of the most
demoralizing thing is when in a battle
royal game is you get limb old early
mm-hmm so now you like ah strap Noddy
got some joint where they grab you up
don't you in prison right so yeah oh did
you gotta fight your way out of prison
against another dude or some wood on one
joint and if you break out they throw
you back into play did you get to go
again dad joy is fired that little
mechanic I'm not gonna front now I'm
gonna tell you right now my first new
players like that is a fire feature Dan
you figure they got the cross plate
right mmm not you you PC you got you
think I even saw bounce to keep more
support if you want you know hopefully
they can separate the lobby you know see
yeah shout to Johnny don't us that gulag
dad guru prison got to fire sir I felt
like I was back I felt like I was Batman
breaking out you don't say well he got
caught in the beam I'd get out they
climb the mountain get out yo doing fine
right so I can't this is crazy
oh say map
it's you money it's it's not it's
nothing that I've seen for so listen six
Billy you know I'm saying day one
smashing everybody I know it's early to
my attic is same for two seasons every
time something dropped I was like this
is dumb
can I jump in for as I have
hot-off-the-press information I'm gonna
read let's go let's go from ventureBeat
and it is going to I actually have this
topic tomorrow night so I may have to
move the time oh brother the beauty
let's go here you go this this is hot
off the presses from ventureBeat right
let's get it Call of Duty warzone
debuted on Tuesday as the shooter series
I have to I need a rebuttal here because
I'm reading an article live on the air
from Forbes that was just posted Call of
Duty warzone hits 15 million players in
three days Wow
three days outpacing record-setting apex
legend this is coming directly from
forbes.com so breaking news well my
brother bull with the millions wow that
listened I don't care what people
download a free link I want to see who
stays that's true that's true it's let's
add again we have to you know what we
have to work we have to equate this to
is how well that free time free-to-play
relevance know it because you're not
letting me finish dude you're cutting me
off like you always do just chill for a
sec let me give my point damn it
the reason what I'm saying is that yes
the free-to-play thing is big yes sure
but we also have to equate to everytime
Call of Duty releases again it's number
one MPD's it's a high sounding game on
that year facts ok if you want to pull
up facts if you want to see who sold the
most games this year 2019 not 2022 9
2019 you at the people that went out and
spent the $60 to play mostly the online
play which is what most coal of Duty
die-hard players they just totally skip
the single-player game it's not it
should not come off as a surprise that
15 million in three days and on top of
that and I'm getting back to exactly
what Congress saying what they the the
new types of play added to this the
graphics to 60fps the gun handling all
of this is why they potentially again
this is just my opinion could take down
fortnight
free to play game for a couple weeks and
they drop off its attic I'm a total
fraud little myself I want to finish
that black hold on since I'm like I
gotta give you the special to bulgy who
did that for you baby could do these out
here you know Smitty Smith Bob do you be
interested battle babe the mass
[Laughter]
it's gonna be a focus we gotta see what
did they maintain that we can write oh
you know they they beat their twitch
views this side they beat their mixed
reviews they beat these views it's free
anyone can download it we got a you know
it's like I said it obviously call the
do be doing really good because it's a
it's a household name and apex and for
Knight has paved the way for
free-to-play battle royale games going
into it so they all downloaded look you
got Pete you got big streamers that's
flame fortnight and apex coming over to
play it wait these go happen to think
away but we can't you can't sleep Friday
Oh movie oh we gotta move or doing too
much you doing the most you know what
emotion we gotta get
[Laughter]
you gotta stop moving okay cause I can't
keep scheme off you cuz I'm not gonna be
able to keep jumping with that damn bass
[Laughter]
next time we got a Microsoft band we got
the GDC and obviously we know the
situation around it but they are still
doing a live stream they're calling a
game stack live so on mixer March 17
through the 18th Microsoft States
they'll be live streaming content and
they plan to share at this year's GDC
starting at 10:00 a.m. Pacific time when
the 17th come learn about the latest
cloud and game development tech from
Microsoft go behind the scenes with the
creators and Xbox game studios and ID
and Xbox program and level up with deep
technical talks and panel discussions by
industry leaders so I wanted to bring
this to the Lord's in the round
um number one and number two points so
number one I want to say in reference to
this you know is there anything anybody
got a chance to look at the list and is
there anything specifically from the
list on the schedule that kind of
excites you there's a two day event and
then the second part will be you know
obviously with the recent events the
parent and stuff like that you know
cancelling e3 you know how do you want
Microsoft to handle their rollouts so
two-part question GDC first you know
game of game live left large anything on
that list excites you and then how do
you amongst off to vote for which stuff
so there's no boom in the room you know
I mean listen I like that they put the
list out right so they put the times out
we know exactly what's happening you
know if something interests you like
maybe what they do you know what the
technology gonna use for Forza if that
interests you you know you're gonna tune
in for this most of us most gamers
especially when it comes to like that
that the technical part of gaming we're
not really so much into I don't
necessarily know how much of the
community is gonna be jumping in it's
interesting that they're putting this
live I think that what I'm excited about
on the second half of the question is
are they going to show something that we
haven't seen already oh you know what
I'm saying are they gonna I mean cuz I
know that they're gonna go deep into the
Xbox series X X X cloud connectivity
that's gonna be very interesting to see
exactly what its gonna be like when
you're playing away from your console
and how easy the new technology is gonna
hold hands with one another um but the
question is what are they gonna show
right you know what I'm saying now we
have we do know that there is at least
one big III event coming all right so we
know that they're there III event is
being planned as we as we speak but are
they gonna show anything I don't wanna
say interesting cuz everything here is
interesting because we're gonna learn so
much about behind the scenes tech so
it's gonna be interesting but are they
gonna show anything that the game was
like myself who are interested in the
hardware and talk about the numbers but
I can't get into the of it like like
addy batch or a dealer or a cult or I'm
like why I tuned into their channels for
that because they really know the you
know the behind the scenes aspect of
building these things cuz their PC
master-race got right um but I'm
interested as a game or to see what this
technology is going to do for me as the
gamer but I'm more interested to see if
Microsoft is gonna be aggressive and
really shocked us with something we
haven't seen question a follow-up
question to that um I'll pass it off
boom now in reference to the second part
of digital only events based on the
situation going on in the room right now
you know how do you want them to handle
this kind of stuff moving forth like we
know you know do you want them to just
kind of just do one thing with like
maybe e3 when they would have done it at
e3 digital-only
and then or do you want them to do like
a series of little mini events you know
it's trickled through tomorrow like how
do you want them to hand because we know
they have to pivot right they had all
that planning towards my three from I
understand like III preparation char
just going I believe senator the Xbox
too they start at like October of like
2019 age that's what they just got their
e3 planning so that's
to work going in so not at that's you
know have to be changed I how do you
want them to handle the rollout of
Series X information in the games well
we had heard prior to the e3
cancellation that we were probably going
to get a show prior right we've been
hearing that whether it was gonna be in
April or May
why we heard that there was gonna be
potentially a reveal of series s alright
they were gonna show what the console
look like I think we should get that
still that that was going to be a
digital event right for the for this
particular year I think what they need
to do is put out that 90-minute show oh
you know what I'm saying and I think it
needs to roll out look if you look at
what Nintendo does Nintendo directs or
their treehouse events are all digital
yes and they root and they get the fan
base crazy excited watch these videos of
people you know in a room right watching
this and they smash characters announce
and it's dude I'm talking about it gives
me goosebumps because those are real
fans they get so excited they're in
they're in a party and even when they're
podcasting we see you know six people
and they're all like dude with the
cameras on and you can see the
excitement and when banjo kazooie was
was announced how crazy the fan base got
so you can still be relevant and be in
the know and be in the news with digital
events now this particular year I think
they still need to take whatever they
were gonna do a 90 minute show and bring
that over to the digital event where
instead of just Phil being out there
they need to bring like if it like for
instance if playground is going to
officially announce fable Oh head of
playground needs to do that he need to
come out explain who he is get out there
and say yes we know that you've been
waiting we have something special for
you but now drop it right there all of
every announcement that's gonna come in
this event whether it's in 30 minutes 60
minutes or 90 minutes it's gonna make
new
they're gonna be hospital people shows
you know IGN even though they're not
covering it you know live on the scene
they're gonna be covering it right so
all of the same excitement and and fire
behind an event like III is it's still
gonna be something special for digital I
think they need to be as aggressive as
they've been being mm-hmm to a pre-event
get the hardware stuff out of the way
yes and just drop gains gains in that in
that III whatever it's gonna be
they'll come enough Lord addict man do
you see the game stack live coming up
you know so anything on that list
excites you and then to how can they
move forward there did you do only Oh
actually there's a couple of things you
might be interested in on this well it
is a lot of hard way I'm not gonna say
it's now 17 on the 17th I'm not on the
dealer crack that I can't oh I don't
like the hardware I leave all that
d-list [ __ ] I didn't dealer but his
eighth date is more than just oh yes
this game stack they talk about gears
for college talk about how getting far
we came gonna stand it they're gonna try
far as game wise and day two but you
might like in exile is gonna talk about
are basically in series and then also
you'd like um gears tactics thoughts or
optimizing for PC there's a segment for
that and then 11:55 we got an Xbox
series X stuff going on so any of that
interest you at all tactics I don't care
what they did autumn eyes it just give
me the
no we talked about how it was under
decay literally you rarely see me
calling on hardware related hardware
because I just wanted to click two
buttons I want to click my mouse twice
or I want to press a on the icon on my
xbox and it load up I don't care about
how it got to that point
mm-hmm all right so they beat it you're
not interested in games that um what
about the whole you know now beautiful
with no formal III right like how do you
want them to handle these digital only
available before they need to throw that
whole III presentation in the bushes and
rework it from the ground up because
they go into that presentation with the
set value that they only have this
amount of time
mm-hmm that's no longer the case mmm so
I think they need to have like maybe a
week or a month to where they have a
couple events that's dedicated to one or
two things for instance like you know
what they're doing one on the Facebook
for you do the one at the beginning that
they were going to designate all the
announcements and then throughout the
month you start dedicating other smaller
ones kind of like directed senator X to
those independent games to the game
paths that way you know you you you
stick in there whole month you get
constant news constant updates and you
know I think it would get it's more
beneficial to spend more time talking
about these independent stuff because
we're going to the next generation we're
going to another console and now you
don't have a 90 60 minute you know
duration that they have to do when it
come to Easter you don't have that
anymore you can you do whatever you want
now right and you know if they just drop
the line demented thing I'd be
disappointed because it's like you're
going you're still going with the
mindset that you're 83 which I doubt
they're gonna do that because they
haven't even rehearse that's though I
highly doubt any that's on that on the
table they're gonna do something
completely unique I just want them to be
a little bit more specific in certain
things okay I want them to be very
community very transparent have a lot of
communication I want by the end of all
of these events or with this one event
there's no more questions because we
store you questions you know obviously
they got a show you know they might show
what the the prices and stuff the GDC
now I would be interested in
I doubt it but you know they might show
that we starving her from the Lockhart
yeah so we might hear stuff on that like
there's still a lot of questions and a
lot of questions on games you know
when's hell-blade gonna come out what's
he'll play - gonna look like is the
gameplay changed like they need to
answer more questions and that's what I
really I just want more answers that's
fair enough
Lord King does game stack interest you
does that lineup of topics interest you
and then how do you want Sony will use
Morse code rate is so vast you may
decide to read like the games I think
issues change in position so the first
GD do you see that okay let me explain
that is it intrigues me for only one
reason
talk that's X cloud all right so I
believe that they're going to flush out
what X cloud truly means because the
audience inside the GDC is it's
different yes okay so the audience is
tech base the audience
it's like optimizations and stuff like
that how did we get said code to do
certain things how you can get this to
perform in this light so their audience
that they're trying to market to and
then trying to push the product to is a
different audience alright so that's the
reason why we tune into that because as
the audience shows that it kind of tips
its hand into what the future holds yes
so you're going to see more along that
tech because a lot of people don't
really understand fully how X cloud
really works and I think you're gonna
get that fleshed out in concrete because
I believe X cloud is going to start
rolling out out of beta and into solid
form right so I believe this is the the
point of okay now we're finished with
the beta this is the data that we have
and this is what helped us get from
point A to point B and this is how we're
gonna roll it out going forward and this
is what we're looking to achieve with
this so this is what I believe that is
truly based upon okay all right so when
you say
combinations of certain games and gears
tactics and stuff like that I truly
believe that it's less like a cold cold
break is talking cold break your stuff
together and trying to see how they can
help each other going forward and who
can leverage what tech going where
that's what I believe that is and of
course I'm always interested in Series X
stuff but I believe it's gonna be
bare-bones reiterations of what we've
been talking about and nothing too much
now
just get it to it this is where um
you're gonna see if Phil can freestyle
oh no Phil's written is crazy
yes you know he definitely can write now
some bars he definitely can go off the
track what scares me with the fact that
III has canceled we know that Microsoft
can go on a stage and put together a
show they feed off the crowd
all right so and and being in the crowd
you handle people going crazy when Keanu
weaves came out they go for shock value
right there big-budget movie going for
shock value can they be that indie movie
they can pull up at your heart you know
now you're telling them Krista Phil
don't got no boss okay well I feel you
but Sony don't got no information little
boy no we gotta see if Phil can produce
this little indie film instead of the
big-budget and he can really get down to
the ground the brass tacks of the
situation can he convey what he's gonna
do in a 90-minute show can he put that
in little squishy Nintendo is the master
of the indie flags you know so they told
you now we're not doing what they do the
big-budget do let them do them we got
this flow disjoint my hair we can get
this popping Sony in the other way they
can do both sony has shown you they can
do both right we don't know new son okay
so that's the jury is still out on that
my fear with the fact that Phil and the
squad yeah has to change stream yeah
right now they're like like like boom
said they've got ready last October yeah
so now you have to change how you're
gonna roll it out maybe for the whole
week of III that they know that the void
is there we can fill that void with
information so one day maybe it's fable
information maybe it's disinformation
and they build up all the way to the end
of the week till he dropped down the
pricing oh if you're listening Microsoft
I have crazy strategies oh this this
strategy here depends on your ability to
work without a crowd yeah never seen as
even without a crowd and that's where
the fear lies in because you stub your
toe here cuz we know your biggest
problem before with those EXO's was the
cringe-worthy jokes king stealing my
balls and kill your maggot David yeah
they can you know you never really been
good oh if the digital presentation
great with a crowd rage and I think I I
think you're yeah I think in trouble I
think they I think they're in trouble
for the simple fact that it takes more
than just putting up stuff on a screen
right you have to do it with a certain
level of fan cache and if you don't have
that cachet in that Flint because
Nintendo got that Flair baby if you
don't have that flip if you don't know
how to present if you don't know how to
do a little shadow and then reveal a
carrier if you don't know how to do
and you don't know how to have the
musical cues you might stub your toe and
remember what messed up this generation
you stub your toe Oh
so at a curiosity King what why would
you prefer them to do it like if I were
to hire me choose a way to do it I would
prefer you like a little less crazy cuz
they didn't have as much as they usually
do but I would like an XO like that so
they was onto something wasn't it yeah
I've really enjoyed the way they did it
and like the information and it was
wasn't the greatest but I felt like the
pacing was good it was great right I
don't want them to do that I don't want
them to go at it as a XO yeah I don't
want them to go at it as a III I want
them to go as as let's say they take
three games right let's say probably
they got 90 games right right so I want
you to do it in batches let's say you
said five games here right five games
right
then dig deep just like you I'm taking
what you said and what Boone said you
have the head of each studio present
their games and their story and you can
do them in each game get a five-minute
clip mmm because like you said time is
not a constraint right right so do it in
that manner and release five to ten
games a day until you at the end of the
week and you end with the price drop and
the mic drop oh but don't do it in the
beginning of the week so you have loud
ease dudes to recover just keep hitting
them with bangers but make sure that you
do it in a way that shows flare style
and substance and make them beg for more
for the next day oh yeah because if you
spill your watch but if you spill your
wad all in one shot trying to knock
somebody out the park when it's meant
necessary oh you will stub your toe
cause they're for a change all right do
you think that I think they should do a
formal you know this is my opinion I
think they should add to start because I
do think they need to do you know
batches they
to do events or a whole month to make
like a fan fest day it's just an entire
month of this and I just one day well
but obviously they would need to launch
it with something well I think that you
know they they do I kind of like how we
have it with destiny with the roadmap
right right like have a month of a road
map on this day this is gonna be shown
like this this is gonna be shown let me
ask you a question what what what do we
lose in this generation the age of
wonder surprise so you know what they
don't have to they don't have to
formally show it all that they could put
on their remember how during the exo
they had one of them is redacted they
could literally just have that okay okay
well you say put the lesser known games
in between a good game and well-known
game and a highly anticipated game and
redact the name or behind the
anticipated game yeah they could do
anything like that or you know for
instance they could you know they could
sneak one they could show something like
let's say they're gonna show up Citians
new gang they can name that as obsidian
I call we're gonna show you bleeding
edge DLC after they show up leading edge
DLC like we got something for you like
blur there's multiple wait that could go
about it but what I really want to ask
you is how would they start it which
started off with it you know that reveal
like that only through the reuleaux the
console what it looks like well
obviously we know what it looks like the
price of it and then show one game one
key game at the end I think you anyways
Roy you saved that for the end you saved
the taking this did the curtains oh I
don't think so
I think we don't care for that we
already know what it looks like we don't
know what's inside I think we only want
to know what don't play on again a
couple years ago where they see but like
part of me feels like that's the reason
like AE threes and stuff they get that
out of all the gate first like we
already know what it is we we know the
name we know what it looks like it's
mighty three no more but I get but but
my point is is why would you hold on to
information that you pretty much already
know because this right
nobody cares no more about we already
knows a box we already know what's
inside the box
nobody know the price of the box and I
believe for them to grab your torch a
super heart don't put color okay has a
$2.00 super chair PlayStation 5 revealed
will make King Benin II brother if they
say anything I've been in I will bend my
knee right back there for you if they
say anything I do think they're gonna do
something unique like because now they
don't have that timeframe
I do think I personally would like them
to show the console go starting it but
you know they don't understand they're
gonna show that card at the end because
they're you know you could use that
argument on both of our sides like what
why show it first when we already know
why she'll laugh I would do it very
simply is this we've been to e3 we've
known what they do
we've watched these threes numerous
times what they do they have to open up
with it thereafter bookend did whatever
they gonna do they offer to open it big
they have to close a big I don't know I
would do it is open it up with Halo
infinite game get it right to it they're
right to it literally it goes into like
a two second trailer all right all right
chief you know we want you to take this
and they go right into game playing they
show five you know four to five minutes
of him doing whatever he's gonna do in
an area and then they and then it feels
and then Phil would walk out like okay
that was that was halo infinite that's
gonna be available this fall landing or
getting into the and then how I would
close it out or how you put the you drop
the flag in the sand and we dope and you
close that with fable mmm that's how you
close it out you close it out with with
like a forest you know you know you you
all the way back you see a forest you
come in you come in you see some sort of
would play you do so you know some some
you know character frighten the monster
and then he does some sort of magic
thing it will black stout fable whatever
it's the milk I love it let me ask you
this doable
when do you do price when do you do do
you do it in middle do you bomb you know
something nude because there's no III
and because we already heard that there
was going to be an event in May April or
May which is more than likely made I
love to see them get the hardware torque
out of the way show show Lockhart
show the Xbox series s standing next to
the X and then you drop price $4.99
$2.99 and cut the black that's how this
is the reason why it gives a rebuttal if
you're trying to rebut games throughout
the week now you offer your dean because
you don't know what they're gonna reveal
next right so you can say on Friday Phil
can come out with the game show whole
suit on you play some jokes and games
with it
and like behind curtain number one and
you know they pull up the curtain in the
Vanna White type of person comes out and
they reveal the price at the bottom of
the Xbox what X Syrian no I go over door
number two and you have this series X
the s you know they reveal the price he
can joke around with it at the end right
because they're still trying to recover
from the games that were knocking their
head lose all week long and then you hit
them with the price and that's when you
put the mic next to me what you want the
mic you want the price lash I want the
see because the biggest thing now is
everybody has a speculation where I
couldn't accommodate because you have
the economy prize because they still
trying to react from games so they rebut
you with games if you give a fire
presentation throughout the week at the
end mmm you drop that price yeah you the
stage you let it be how it is because
the bigger problem right now is
financially in Dane age right now for
these come on so we don't know if he's a
year - whatever
mm-hmm financially some of us might not
be able to reach that king others it got
a question he said could we hear the
panel discussions on Sony Jim Ryan
strategy Jim lying dance moves lines
because he's about the tapuwae
listen the strategy is whatever
Microsoft's a baby I'm gonna give you
beyond PlayStation got a jib dance move
emoji I've done yeah yeah yeah yeah
making good points
the to the GDC that seems that no one
likes except me you know there are some
dealers going on behind my sakes but
anyway moving on
oh yeah but I'm looking forward to it
because I want to see like I said some
talking to do check how the studios are
implementing it you know I like how Xbox
queuing game studios is all working
together you understand so I want to
hear that sharing of tech because let's
be real that's what made Sony Studios
really great they all work with each
other they all share information I like
that culture that Xbox game studio is
trying to mimic so that is dope to me
obviously I'm a huge project as cloud
supporter so when I seen that
information have its own day I
definitely want to know what's going on
that and to King's point the next
raishin of it because as we know right
now as God is using Xbox 1s server X
right they're not even using the series
X stuff yet so being that they they I
want to see how far they away from maybe
getting out of beta
maybe another announcement the other
thing I want to hear about is um them
going to PC because I'm hearing
rumblings about that shot at the brass
Sam's a couple other people you know
them having s cloud in the PC browser to
me is a direct competitor to stadia and
I'm saying and I would love to see that
feature so any features with X cloud in
that respect I'm definitely excited as
far as the rollout I mean look ya'll
making good points you know I'm saying
um we got a see we got a see I'm with
King though I am a little concerned
because like I said this was being
planned from October this is a major
pivot now you have to change everything
and you have to do it right and still
maintain boombastic moments to get
everybody hyped up and this is where I
feel then Tendo has the advantage they
in doing this over Sony and Microsoft
they know how like boom said how to get
their base so excited where it's just
like wow oh my god like they've been
this ain't nothing new to them they they
stay used to these type of bars you know
that this is a de justice fulfill and
like King said I gotta stay told on it
like I've said it on next podcast
yesterday I have not been a fan of their
digital presentations when it's their
own now when it's game awards that was
what I'm talking about a new day a new
Microsoft aggressive boom boom I want
them to keep that kind of cadence and
pacing no cringe-worthy moments it
cannot treat this like it's an inside
Xbox imma be highly upset can I just
throw something go for that I think it's
the contributing factor to you're not
only to your fear but while it should be
curved right um if you look back to the
i hate when i forget people's names the
the intern yes bob they stood up for
phil yeah yeah it she is
exactly the shot in the arm yes
Microsoft needed but besides that
besides her thinking outside the box
just what has me excited for this
digital then it's the rehiring of Jared
West who are not talking good boy not
about this man good what is it and what
and but where he came from or what he
did for the 360 yes he did for Netflix
when he got there and what he has
started to do for the Xbox brand now
that he got back in December of 2019 he
is in charge of all of the marketing for
the Xbox series X and s if that's what
it's called right and I feel that he is
going to make sure that the same
freshness right and excitement that came
with the Xbox 360 while he was there
absolutely is going to bring that
tenfold over to my soul now not to your
point where you are giving me confidence
is sits then right Cindy Walker I think
her name is yes since then and since the
game Awards they have been in the mind
share it feels like every two or three
weeks we get some juicy Xbox one
x-series X is knocking and this is what
I'm talking about specially as a as a
platform that did not win the last
generation they've got to do everything
in their power to galvanize people to
get people excited to say yo I might
consider getting this you know I'm
saying that and I I have to agree I feel
there has been a change right it's been
very any chip Mac what's up oh it's been
a it's been a very different mindset and
I like I just want to see it continue
only only who is why I got a little bit
of nervousness is because I just want to
see now that continue on their own
digital platform so now they do whatever
they showed a that shows they got
playing quick concise aggressive nice
play until Kings point
you know maybe sense face out price to
the very end hit them with the bangers
anybody gay make the devs come out do
what you got to do but it has to be that
constant trickle of information no
cringe no I don't want it to be it means
to appease the horklops know why gloves
and these do
to appease the hardcore game it can't be
a a promotional matter of fact you know
I'm like a [ __ ] like the Xbox me the
inside expose always feel like it's some
marketing show like they can't be that
that's awesome so I'm gonna give them
you know give me a fair shot see what
they do and the last bit is they got to
do that the direct flip which is that
what the Nintendo always does it's that
one last moment oh by the way and their
memoir their base goes crate
Microsoft has to do it whether it be
fable somebody's something that people
go yeah over like remember how we felt
or live stream oh my god hell bleats
what what I need like those type of what
cannot be yes it's got to be very high
you know you know what and I think this
is where it changes I don't think we get
the leaks that we normally do because
remember last last year they work really
hard on faking people out now that
distance stuff is internal is in-house I
don't believe that you have to work as
hard as to you know to fake anybody out
because they have to go and have to set
up and they have to rehearse right now
have to go through that and people
seeing stuff while I'm being put
together so you have too many leaky hose
right you know and I thought that
Microsoft did a great job last year I
think they can do even better job this
year right with the level of surprises
and they can also take liberties with
things because no longer are they up
against this imaginary clock right
remember they would go than Sony would
go then right would go so I believe now
that when you can control your own
destiny that can be a blessing and a
curse
yeah um you have to know pace right my
biggest fear just pace it yeah I agree
is them putting those just certain
people I really want them to stay away
from going forward and I want them to
have a different type of format don't
look at it as an XOS keep that away ass
let is make this dead you
when each day they showed um Xbox X Xbox
1 X right and it was talking to her
Mikey bar and they had everybody was
going on to that real yeah and it was
talking about the tech and and what we
did when we put this down and we was
looking for I always thought that real
that that there little segment that they
did before they showed it was so finally
done it was so incredible and so
powerful and I thought that was a step
forward now I really believe that was
produced perfectly mm-hmm
take that same format when introducing
your games oh you know take that same
format when you're going forward remove
everything else because you know they
won't have anybody there so it won't
have to be the stuff that they were
doing before
like I said they play great in front of
a crowd they don't play great alone and
I want them to play great alone y'all
giving me a little bit more confidence
so I'll give once you move on to the
I'll give you my spiel on what's
happening Sony what people can expect
and then I'll be out I know Debra let's
get there go again we might want
something but I think the realm of
reality is gonna be one show I think
they're not gonna stick too far away
from that and they're gonna have one
well show I don't know if it's gonna
have a bunch of cringe-worthy and it's
just you know I hope they say that's all
I was saying if they do one show I want
it more that that EXO style than the
inside of yeah I just want to eat three
style you know saying that's gonna be
pretty great but look we got to move on
but Laurel does not have much time so
we're gonna get into it man obviously
the Twitter streets were in a tizzy you
know I got some news obviously um shot
the Lord brand it is a fantastic
addition he actually made this
prediction here on the islands podcast
plug plug if you were listed but brother
got stoned he got stoned live on on ILP
they had no love
they through the shame they did all the
game of throwing stuff then they threw
tomatoes they did everything to him but
um he lived to talk about it the day has
come
horizon zero dawn that's right it's
right that it it's officially you know
come to PC Harman house had made the
announcement and very spooky out here so
I want to give it to boo you know with
this information that has dropped what
do you feel what nuggets you would have
drop about this this moment with
harassing dog
well first of all horizons you were
doing is a game that I have been
champion for for quite some time it's
one of my favorite games of the
generation and next no I haven't
platinum did and I probably never will
to be honest with you I'm I beat the
game went back in started trying you
knows you know get you know get some of
those achievements a new DLC came out
which was fantastic and really really
enjoyed a Louise the character who loved
the world that she is I've been brought
to loved that this came from a team that
was only known for kill zone and really
am looking forward to the part two that
eventually is gonna be here getting it
to come to PC first of all this if you
are one of these console people that
just don't look outside of your window
listen this is common this is okay right
now Sony is starting small and yes the
game came out in 2017 yes it's three
years old at this point and yes it's on
PC but you know Kojima's game is gonna
be on PC at the same time and that game
just came out at the end of 2019
something maybe it's not gonna be Dane
date now but you have to think that Sony
is seeing the money that Microsoft is
making who they're gonna want a part of
this and you should be cheering this on
and the days of you having a game locked
behind a piece of plastic are done and
if you live in that era
I got a console for Xbox 360 because you
have
understand when they bring these games
to other people especially with Sony
they're going to get more money to
invest in a studio we gotta remember
when you look at Sony as a company as a
whole right now the only thing that's
holding them in the black is the
PlayStation brand now granted yes their
movie division is doing well with their
animation and of course the spider-man
films and and what they have coming out
with more vyas and venom but the reality
is is that they need to keep the money
flowing to make investments in new
studios and new games if you don't have
and and here's the thing the I think the
main cog behind this move is because you
I'm looking at you PlayStation freud's
by these first party games you put them
on a piece of paper and you tweet about
it that's what makes you a Ford if I can
still more of these first party games to
other gamers who may not have a ps4 / PS
5 they're going to be able to sell more
copies wouldn't it be awesome to say
that they sold 30 million copies of
spider-man 2 instead of the 15 that only
the only 15 million PlayStation Eye
gamers yes of course it is and you know
what the one that that can occurred that
that could really harp on this question
and really bring some light to what I'm
saying is came because he's a
businessman and he understands that the
more people that you market to the more
customers you have the more customers
you have the more money you're gonna
make for your company and if you think
of that I say go to college
[Laughter]
lissa Bay oh can you get your job to be
what's to hear your bar is very bad day
I'd be kick or this alright so gym dance
move Ryan has went to the great school
of Phil dominus maximus offensive
animals Ryan's fearless leader you
understand when you're looking up to
your leader and you want to emulate him
you do things that your leader has done
already you put games on PC oh well um
listen boom is on to something when he
tells you that he's a hundred and five
million of you guys because every time I
hear it was like 120 then was one six
then it was on five
you guys numbers is really flip-flop and
doesn't look good in the light I'm
telling you never did I never believed
it I don't care all right because you
know why I don't care and you know why I
don't believe you guys and y'all be
taught and tower numbers and all this
other stuff is because if you have 110
million and you release a game as great
as spider-man you're supposed to play
games let's say half of you people
should buy the game it should be 15
million of them sold not 10 not 5 so the
question is what's really out there
what's really in the sauce what's really
in the street because I don't really
believe you guys because your numbers
adding up so when you say something like
15 million in three days and call a duty
war zone that kind of makes sense right
it kind of makes sense because you know
those fans out there going support it's
about support this would not be
happening if you support it it wouldn't
this would not be coming to your
doorstep if you was actually about that
wallet instead of talking a tweet and
comes down
stop talking and tweet and get out there
start ending these games and buying
these games because you brought this
upon yourself see when Microsoft started
putting their games on PC is because
they had to they had to they had to sell
right they had to make this self viable
right they had to go to another path so
what is good for the goose is good for
the gander my friend so you have not
been out there supporting in the manner
that you claim that you have because if
you were this would not be knocking at
your door if you sold ninety million in
spider-man I can guarantee you that
stuff would not be going to PC so when
the next games flying on PC and your
little tears start running down your
little faces you start saying no
these in my exclusive well you should
have supported your exclusives because
this wouldn't be happening to you in 10
million if I got a hundred you know what
happens if you have a hundred and ten
million and you only sell five do you
understand what the boss looks at you
are you doing with the is the 90 million
at what you say this kick games like
that they call the duties the bad is the
third parties that generally you know
tend to dable MPD and device share as
far is that what we're saying they need
to be or that level how can you get to
these numbers
why is your exclusives got to go
someplace to make their money over there
why can't you exclusive make their money
at home it's not good it's not good when
you're looking at the whole pie and 10
million sitting in the room saying boy
we just saw half of that we'd be rolling
in the money and you come back and do
Zeus's lightning pockets they come back
we only so five behind out there and
stop pushing this way so we can get this
stuff done stop talking these numbers
and I'm not pushing 110 games was the
one game that's gonna sell one on one
and I'm gonna tell you what game does
that because what does I have no problem
with this dooda dooda so all you do in
ten or so 50 million
how many Bret for the wild was sold I
gotta look at it over that we got a big
piscatella
all I will say in defense of somebody is
that you're gonna say you want that
diverse piece of pie so it's still
selling five it's not bad
obviously it's not you know what those
other that as far as the base
I'm telling you any way you look at it
okay okay okay
yes this is this is Wiz know her Chuck
this is not hurt you oh yeah all right
you have 12 teraflops only using two
[Laughter]
were you only going to use two diversity
of titles is important to eddie
kasalivich ever get a honey no Oh Erin
Jake put up the crest in the realm on a
94 to I so chat please tweet me this
section please please Mary Smith though
Spencer hey Sony we don't believe you
need more people bars Wow I gotta give
up I gotta give about who did that for
you very smooth Betty look we go get our
attic you got to get off real quick and
I know Bulls gotta go let bullets let me
know when you got to go out I'll try I
do think that I've always been
astounding from when it comes to the
Xbox one when your games on PC does
devalue your brain but they people act
like it's huge no you guys say and it's
not necessarily like devaluing the game
Steve valuing the customers on your
platform you get people the option to
buy it on another platform like placed a
PC then there's this thing called steam
people can go to and buy all their games
on Steam and just buy that one game on
PlayStation so now instead you know
instead of PlayStation getting these you
know the subscriptions the you know the
the cut they get from selling all third
party some people are just gonna get
stuff on Steam
is it a larger amount no it's not cuz
there is such thing as console gamers
and there is such thing as PC gamers but
when you got probably got a good amount
of people that have both and if you give
them the option they're not gonna buy it
on both right they're gonna buy it on
their PC and they're gonna play it on
their PC
I don't think it's I don't think it's a
big deal you know they they might lose
some you know might share when it comes
to the console thing but we're talking
like pennies right when they're making
dollars by offering it to the hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of people on
Steam that don't work that would refuse
to get a console right so it's the right
mood do I think it devalues the brand a
little bit yeah but it's not enough to
justify not getting that money what
about the fact that it's three years
later though like it's so much later the
cycle is exclusive that's devalue the
brand it's like giving people options to
play your game on another platform right
for instance you know people that have
one on both consoles you know let's say
that you know someone just jumps the gun
it just buys a PC because of this I
don't know why you would do that because
they're under the impression now
everything's coming to PC they're on the
PC platform now they're not on the
PlayStation 4 PlayStation 5.1 they're
not paying for your live anymore
they're not buying your third-party
games that you get a cut of because they
switch to PC it's the same thing that
happened with Xbox and Xbox says it day
one you know they import doors that a
lot more but you know at the end of day
it's like I said there is a vast
majority of people that is on that PC
platform that it does not matter what
you say they will never buy a console
and that's the target for people first
sony sony doesn't care about the little
in between people that own book also
because they know at the end of the day
you know it's a very small percentage
it's not worth you know it's it's worth
to them devaluing the brain just a
little bit to these people that have
both to make sure that everyone on Steam
gets the game oh boy how we doing I want
to get my bars off then get you out here
how much time you got yeah yeah I got I
got ten okay I just want to make sure
let me give my boss because we gotta get
Baba
listen man huh this is talking about the
exclusive day but um look man you know
it's sad sad times for PlayStation Lords
man oh yeah it was looking real spooky
or social media with these react
since I was hearing but try to talk
about the thrashing of the or oh yeah
what yet bro people were talking like
life-threatening to Hermann hosted the
story I was told there's more yeah and
I'm getting people ready this is not
going to be the last you know more will
come oh this is the process yeah it's
gonna sell well curse arise it's gonna
sell on Steam it's going somebody get
you did $10 super chart from gene the
game at that horizon zero dawn on PC is
just an ad for horizon zero dawn to
these next-gen consoles are talking to
PC users Kojima is second party dreams
will need PC to it's above MLB is
forcing Sony to go multiply you know
what it's like I said I've said from the
start remember when I used to argue the
good old five like look like Sony owns
all these games yeah and they're letting
the ball I said debt they own death
stranding but remember huge I got it
with you go over I was like they all
these games they're coming to PC and
they're letting them come to PC all I'm
gonna say is you know I get it
PlayStation law as I understand the
frustration you know saying you know no
for that but by Xbox ones they they they
are familiar with this process they know
what is to come
you know said is how it goes but you
know you even got the developer and
producer of horizon zero dawn chastising
y'all for your actions let's go we go we
gonna make a bill but we got to read the
spirited passage to good word of Lord
Reverend Sam Sharma he's there Reverend
I've gotta go to Revelation chapter 4
verses 1 through 6 let's do some Bible
reading and we're gonna go a brother you
know first first one States you say
which brings us to gang being exclusive
after a while it's not sure if you the
party game to a different platform even
if the architecture is similar the
submission guidelines testing all of
this cost course costs a lot first two
reads all this work and cost are
incurred so many people can enjoy the
game if you already bought it
obviously you played and enjoyed it the
assumption is the transaction what's
fair if you bought a console of the game
yet got a console in a game
we make gains because we generally want
to delight in the detain people's any
chance developers get to do that with a
new audience
they shake if verse 3 if you are angry
and think this is a betrayal because a
game will now be played by more players
you are being unkind to yourself you're
letting yourself think that you have
exclusivity over a game somehow defines
yourself worth you are wrong and the
final verse you're worthy i capable a
little bit o capable of lovely things
games are entertainment and art we make
for you
you're not defined by them love them but
don't let them be your sense of self you
are worth a lot be kind to yourself I
[Laughter]
get it they're not really worried about
like it's like I said the exclusive
devaluing the brand they're worried
about the exclusive devaluing the
ecosystem right people might lead to PC
to play these games and come back to
PlayStation but chances are if a PC
gamer picks this game up on PC he's
already got a PC he ain't buying his
third parties on the console already so
I'm given the option to that platform
anyway yes there is a such thing as a
console gamer and there's there's a PC
game like they are things yeah man do we
get we got gene right so get them so we
gotta find out from Jonathan B last time
I checked every PC has a Microsoft logo
on it so have fun playing horizon on
your Xbox this summer okay you got the
emotes the who did that for you got God
put that up I got involve I got a who
did that for you were to bill hey so Lee
get your bags ready we head into pieces
yeah IIIi have every intentions
everything's coming because if you look
at it I think the only reason to arise
it's coming so soon is because they
already did this for death straining not
too long ago so it was easier
yeah I have a feeling God Awards gonna
come soon yeah Jonathan be eagle that's
probably the best culture I've heard we
got to read the good word from the
brother to be the place that he had to
chastise his old place devalue the brand
maybe just a little bit when it's not
relevant enough to not justify going for
the millions of potential customers
because you're putting on a platform
that has more active users then the
consoles and you double the revenue for
the games you might get a better bigger
budgeted game for going into the next
one you wouldn't necessarily don't even
think it's about the active view I just
take a look it's out of the cycle
already
you don't say they've made their money I
don't know we'll see they right now they
hold Herman is holding firm that that's
not happening that's what you say right
now because you know you say you in the
ballroom addicts in a blue robe there's
articles where Microsoft said it was
gonna come down so what you say it is
like right right so you're saying it yet
so busy you say what happens happens
like yo we wanted to check on me oh
listen is coming dating day oh dude you
did this to yourself
you did this to yourself if you wanted
it if you wanted it to stay in the house
you wanted it to stay close to you you
shouldn't treat it as better you wanna
cry talk about get a PC but you know fax
box so we'll get a PC for your
PlayStation stuff too now that we gonna
move on from that
Jim dance move Ryan's once that bread
bro
okay you know what listen Jonathan I
mean Christopher Hart Chris afar I want
you to go buy a PC right now so you can
get more teraflops out so you can play
it better on PC who did
okay there he wants to say king of the
bushes let's get some real bushes emotes
in there for Christopher let's put him
in the bushes cool cuz you know what
Christopher at the end of the day you
ain't in the real so you can't use the
bush with the mostly positive reception
of orientable of the West how do you
think Microsoft should handle their
continued relationship with moon studios
and the Ori franchise the choices are a
sign moon studios immediately lock Ori
into the Xbox ecosystem B maintain
current relationship let moves will
decide the fate of or E or C I don't
care until they fix them bugs in the
game
boom stick exhale Bobcats brother from
another mother returning gloriously it's
been a long time where can I find people
find you what do you have going on sir
well iris you can find me alright on
Twitter I'm almost out I think I'm
clocking in almost 90,000 tweets I'm
very busy and yes you could find me on
Twitter at mr. boomstick XL easiest way
to find me DM is open to all and yes if
by some chance you do message me that
you're not following me I will message
you I will look at your your DM and we
will talk I enjoy talking with this
community
primetime gaming is going live tomorrow
evening at 8 p.m. as it does every
Monday evening guys and we don't have a
guest as of yet I'm kind of trying to
lock down somebody to be in there I'm
working on someone who's just I'm
waiting on the thing but we are gonna
have our regular panel of amazing you
know our regular panel members that will
be there for the two full hours of
course this week is going to include
breakfast boom on Friday and Thursday's
Xbox Factor podcast but I do would like
to make an announcement as this is a way
for me to assist in curbing the everyday
nervousness that people are
I'm going to be adding one additional
live cast on Tuesdays for 60 minutes for
the egg is gonna be an additional Xbox
factor podcast where's ME games and I
are gonna tackle one particular topic
and we're gonna break it down and I'm
doing this this is like I said as soon
as the world kind of gets back along its
access we will get back to regular three
live shows because it is a lot to do
when you have to write these on these
shows but for now to kind of assist in
helping this community deal with the
situation that's currently ongoing
within the world and to curb some fears
and to give you something to listen to I
am going to add one additional show per
week to the fold again it's it's only
gonna be on Tuesdays it's gonna be
probably at noon and it's gonna be only
60 minutes or so but it's it's another
show that you could look forward to
again kind of just calm people's fears
with everything that's going on with the
world yeah they're much appreciated but
that is so huge obviously what's going
on you know I have to admit man I was
really looking forward to podcasting
today you know saying just like I said
get our minds off everything and again
people are in their homes they need
things to do so we could provide that
value that entertainment you providing
an extra show again gives teen people
things to do and I guess I haven't been
ism like I said earlier is proud to be a
gamer right now because you know we are
lucky that this hobby allows us to dance
like this and still have fun during
these kind of conditions so salute to
you both for that and again salute to
the awesome if you have not watched it
on a double barrel game the awesome
charity stream that we did for my
brother Lord dizzy it was amazing we did
a lot for the community
shout out to Xbox quick Mike Ibarra Rand
outdoors any games boom it was a man of
course the amazing well me hood you know
I'm saying look out for him soon and um
yeah man it was phenomenal so let's get
these outros go on Lord addict where can
the fire people find you and still
riding for fortnight
but I'm the only one on this panel being
realistic you can follow me on Twitter
at a lot at it IOP yes you can find on
youtube at gaming addict that's that's
the mystery can also find me on twitter
you know for i love it i love it
you know definitely you know i want to
thank everyone for coming I want to
thank boomstick for coming on you know
we definitely we we had almost 200
people let's get it over a hundred
before there's four of you and they'd
like to come on you know we definitely
because you know that we had some stuff
going on with the you know the virus and
stuff like that
we have delayed the community day
because obviously you can see that uh
Lord sovereigns I hear either Lord down
but you know we'll definitely be looking
out for Twitter will give you more
updates on that playing Call of Duty I'm
down for that I'm all about that
community day you know one good thing
about being a podcasters we don't have
to shut it down from the safety of our
homes Odell once again you know I will
see you next week because we always yeah
so again salute to um my brothers Lord
Soph you don't saying sir he'll be back
soon and like I said Senate's wishes and
everything like that Lord King wicked
you sir all right so Kos is coming up
this week as you can see right here
display boxes those those display cases
that I'm putting up and stuff like that
and those are the statues that's in the
boxes I'm gonna be honest which was a
little bit depressed because I won't get
a chance to see my brothers the West
Coast brothers Jay
bone and the ruler McQueen yo Chris you
know in stone de jour you know um though
the whole Cali family and I don't get a
chance to hang out with Cole because I
definitely wanted to you know spend more
time with Colton you know boom was in
the house and there's a lot of things I
was gonna meet mods and hang out with
Enrique like it's so many things and
then I had to take a step back and say
okay King you can't be as selfish as you
want to be oh you know you have to
really dial it back because you know at
this point in time everything is in
peril you know there's people in the
streets passing away and this stuff is
really serious and we want everybody to
be safe first and foremost all right
this is not a joke it's not a game this
is very serious if you think it's a joke
in the game I know I joke around and I
play around a lot but I want you guys to
be safe at all times as much as possible
don't take unnecessary risks don't do
things that you won't normally do and if
you can't protect yourself a little bit
more just do a little bit more just go
that little extra mile because you never
know what may save your life um so
anyway like I was saying um you can
follow me on Twitter
King David OTW you can jump on Xbox Live
where I'm rocking at and if you want to
play with me pause on PlayStation nation
you know my tag there is Xbox 360 level
oh one I'm not joking and that's my
joint and it was so great that I wasn't
able to change my name cuz it's mine and
I'm not giving it up very the grove was
lit today again Sleuth everybody that
pulled up we had a fantastic show you
don't say again check out lots of gaming
there that keep please support those
articles that really helps us all the
coverage and retweeted spread the word
really really helps us and again fun
show with definite looking forward to
that's all I got if anybody's got
anything else we are up out of here so
everybody Joe yesterday
[Music]
[Music]